hi there Steve here Steve Kaufman to
talk about language learning what else
I'm back home after an exciting month of
travel to Israel and Greece really
enjoyed it I enjoyed using my Greek to
some extent I was with another couple as
I said Chinese couple so we were
speaking a lot of Chinese in Greece in
Israel I didn't really get very far in
my Hebrew but I'm gonna get back to it
as part of my whole effort to learn the
languages of the Middle East Arabic
Farsi and eventually Turkish and that's
what I got to look forward to but today
I want to talk about something else I
want to talk about combining your
favorite grammar book with link so when
I was in Greece
I bought this series Greek series here
epic e epic in honesty Allah Nika McKay
epic you know nice tell any car let's
communicate or communicate in Greek very
good book cuz I like I'm a sucker for
buying books and the problem always is
that these are books that have you know
easier content than I've been struggling
with in Greek I mean I had my mini
stories which was easy and that got me
started doing quite well acts in Greek
and then at the next level is these
podcasts on the Acropolis which are
difficult so here I have a lot of sort
of intermediate material with some
grammar explanations which I like to
refer to from time to time but there are
words that I don't know so I was sitting
there I said how do I incorporate this
into link at first I started reading
through it and all the words that I
didn't know I would just underline them
and I had the intention of perhaps
trying to import those as words into
link and then I thought to myself hey
maybe instead of doing that I should
just type these texts for which I have
the audio and I have been listening to
the audio and of course when I listened
to the audio the words that I don't know
I don't know them so I said to myself
maybe I should actually copy the whole
text for which I have the audio and
imported
so I said but you know I can go one
better than that I use my iPad here and
I use Google Documents and with Google
Documents I can dictate so I can dictate
in Greek so and that actually is quite a
good exercise so I'm you know let's find
a page here so I have a page that I'm
looking at and let's see you and see
where was it okay so I get out my buddy
call it here Google Documents and I
switch my keyboard to agree because I
can I can have as many different
keyboards as I want and what I didn't
realize before was that to press on that
little globe on your keyboard if you
hold it down you'll see all of the
different keyboards that you have like I
have Chinese and Japanese and French and
stuff but then you can actually dictate
which is tremendously helpful because
then you don't have to worry about
spelling you don't have to worry about
accents you just dictate it and it is
surprisingly accurate occasionally you
have to go in and change a few things
it's not only accurate a little
forgiving so if you don't put the
emphasis on the right word it still
seems to know what you're trying to say
a lot of the time so here I have Vento
Pertamina Oppo Sina
II Korea's official talk levitus k VK
IPO p eople elos steam reception an AE
party came at blah blah blah so at that
speed the dictation picks it up and so I
have now dictated five lessons from this
book for which I have the audio and I've
been listening to the audio I have
imported them into link so I read it I
dictate it so that's giving me exposure
to it the words that I don't know it
doesn't matter I can pronounce them
that's a very useful exercise then I get
into link and I read through it again
this time I click on the words that I
don't know in doing that I come
across a lot of words that were yellow
in which I now know so I move them to
known so that's another useful exercise
now I've gone through this thing twice
when I listen to it again I understand
it so much better so this is something
I'm going to do I'm gonna go through
there's three books in this series the
first book is too easy and so I'm not
gonna do it there but in book 2 and book
3 I'm gonna go through use dictation get
those you know written up important them
in the link and that'll take me a little
further in my pursuit of Greek so I just
passed that on as something that I
developing earth-shattering but some of
you may find that useful the dictation
exercise is quite helpful because first
of all you'll see those sounds that you
don't pronounce that well because those
are the ones that the dictation software
doesn't quite pick up when you go back
in and change them that's helping you
and your spelling it's reinforcing the
you know the vocabulary for you and the
exercise of reading out loud is a good
thing and all of that is helping me get
this material into link so that I can
get the new words into my database so
that I can eventually learn them and
it's a way of accessing some easier
material and I think very often these
beginner books which I always use
whether it be teach yourself or
colloquial and I've always struggled
with how do we how do we integrate these
with link and we do have some of them we
have Benny Lewis's you know series in
different languages available at link
for you to use but many of us by a
similar or by other series that we like
or it could be you know in different
languages in French others you know
programs that I'm not familiar with so
this is one way of integrating them with
your study at link so there you have it
I hope you found that interesting if you
enjoy these videos please subscribe
thank you for listening bye for now
[Music]